[Musique]
à paris dans le quartier du marais au
milieu des bobos il est une personne qui
ne se déplace jamais sans un étrange
bâton de pèlerin
voilà si on est handicapé on ne peut pas
passer si on a une poussette qu'on ne
peut pas passer pour berline c'est le
bâton de la colère et tout est une
histoire de centimètres par l'arrêté
municipal
il doit y avoir au minimum un passage
d'un mètre 60 de large
là j'ai mon fameux bateau qui donc est
entre le premier blocage et la terrasse
et on le voit qu'on n'a pas les 1 m 60
au premier run moi je me plains pas
c'est un plaisir de manger en terrasse
comme aimant les gens ils sont contents
le soleil et tout est fait pour
voilà ils sont très très content
oui voilà fort mi temps je préfère un
mec de toute la russie
c'est à l'étang du magazine
effectivement on prend toute la voit
plus personne peut circuler il n'y a pas
de problème c'est la jungle
perline ne croit pas si bien dire
à la nuit tombée avec le niveau sonore
des terrasses la tension monte d'un cran
et un patron de bar propose une solution
radicale
kate et rasputin a déçu tout apprécié la
vie j'étais dieu personne l'homme a des
centaines d'allier parfois venus de loin
ces touristes locataires airbnb venus
profiter des nuits parisiennes et
accusés de semer la pagaille dans les
immeubles
se plaignent du bruit et c'est le
quartier qui vive si vous ne voulez pas
vivre en ville ne le fait pas partez à
la campagne il vaut peut-être quand tu
es alors les habitants du marais sont
ils condamnés au départ
ce quartier l'un des plus anciens de
paris à cheval sur les 3e et 4e
arrondissements connais une guerre de
voisinage jamais vu depuis le début des
années 2000 les bars se sont multipliées
dans un rayon de cent mètres 33 terrasse
attire tant permanence des milliers
d'habitués et le quartier est devenu un
repère à touristes
résultat selon les riverains un niveau
sonore insupportable jour et nuit et des
locations airbnb à grande échelle qui
chasserait les vrais habitants des lieux
alors malgré ses airs de fête le marais
serait-il devenu invivable querelles de
clocher au coeur du quartier le plus
branché de france
[Musique]
perline on n'a pas eu à chercher bien
loin pour former son armada de
protestataires bonjour ça va très bien
merci
hilda habite juste au dessus d'une des
plus grandes terrasses du quartier et
quand elle ouvre sa fenêtre
quand j'ouvre le matin ma fenêtre je
dévoile allons faire cela en face parce
qu'elle s'est ouvert tout en bas
du bruit c'est tout le temps 7 jours
c'est au fait c'est pas chez moi non
mais si je sais pas chez moi avec le
brouhaha incessant hilda ne vit plus que
fenêtres fermées pour s'endormir
elle n'a trouvé qu'un seul moyen
efficace des fois je prends un td placer
pour donner un petit peu
bon j'ai la force je suis obligé de
dormir je mange avait souvent le bruit
ne s'arrêteraient donc jamais une
nuisance que la loi aujourd'hui condamne
de jour comme de nuit
mais étrangement sans préciser à partir
de quel niveau sonore commence le
dérangement pour en avoir le coeur net
nous sommes venus avec un sonomètre à
13h en pleine journée
l'appareil mesure environ 60 décibels
devant la fenêtre d'hilda l'équivalent
du passage d'un train
mais il n'ya pas que le bruit des
terrasses qui exaspère les habitants il
y à aussi celui des locations
temporaires le marais a battu un record
l'année dernière avoir eu pendant l'été
plus de touristes avec 66300 séjour pour
le seul site airbnb que d'habitants au
nombre de 65 mille dans le quartier les
propriétaires loueurs ferait la loi les
touristes encombrés de valises sont
omniprésents à tel point que les
riverains préfère témoigner à visage
caché
les locations à la journée sur trois
jours
on a beaucoup parce que je vois arriver
les valises des qui peut vendre je m'en
vais c'est invivable invivable entre la
bouffe les cribles à les odeurs c'est
fini quartier cet habitant du marais
depuis 1968 se sentent exclus de son
propre immeuble
excédé il affirme que les forces de
l'ordre n'interviennent plus il aurait
donc commencé à faire justice lui-même à
deux immeubles de l'art jean claude
guillot orchestre une riposte légal il
avait choisi le marais pour son calme
aujourd'hui ils déchantent dans son
immeuble une douzaine d'appartements
sont louées en permanence par des
touristes
il a même posé des instructions en
plusieurs langues pour établir des
règles de bonne conduite
nous aimerions vous rappeler que cet
immeuble n'est pas un hôtel ou un site
touristique des gens vivent ici
ne parlez pas trop fort et garder le
niveau sonore de votre télévision à un
niveau normal pour respecter nos
conditions de vie
nous espérons que vous respecterez ces
règles de base il en anglais
photo cl mais en italien en espagnol
chinois ce qu'est ce qu'un voeu pieux
j'ai même eu des gens qui sont trompés
des tâches qu'ils ont fait pour suis
rentré chez moi
bourré comme c'était pas possible
il croyait qu'il était au 2e et au 1er d
effraction en pleine nuit
le ver incroyable quelqu'un est en train
de rentrer bon les années 2 comme ça
thomas kiriazis jean claude guillot a
déplacé le combat sur le terrain
juridique en alertant les pouvoirs
publics sans grand succès ça ce sont les
lettres que nous avons adressé à la
mairie en direction du logement en 2012
septembre 2012 et ainsi que les
nombreuses notes qu'on a envoyé aux
copropriétaires qui fait de l'allocation
touristique
je refais à nouveau depuis tous les
trois mois des relances pour qu'il nous
tient informés de leurs actions qui
paraît normal et de ce qui aura été fait
nous nous
à 19 heures c'est le début de l'apéro
les terrasses sont pleines
dans la rue le sonomètre dépasse les 65
décibels
l'équivalent du bruit d'une machine à
laver en fonctionnement
[Musique]
chez elle perline retrouve sa fille
lucile salut à lui fava à toi ben ça va
bien bien sûr
on est obligé de fermer parce qu'à cause
du bruit on peut pas laisser ouvert
lucile nous montre le système qu'elle a
inventée pour trouver le sommeil
alors si c'est ma chambre donc c'est là
que je dors toutes les nuits et c'est là
que j'ai ma petite astuce du ventilateur
pour ne pas entendre le bruit le bruit
des terrasses et me concentrer sur un
bruit plus calme plus générale
donc voilà j'ai ça fait nuit et pendant
deux heures et demie le matin en me
réveillant les temps c'est comme ça
toutes les nuits même si ces extrêmes
c'est ça ou je dors presque pas toutes
les nuits ce soir hilda a l'impression
d'avoir perdu une bataille
en bas de chez elle elle assiste
impuissant à l'ouverture d'un nouvel
établissement
c'est une très peur et qui vient
d'ouvrir dans en attendre pour voir
qu'est ce que ça donne si ça va faire
encore plus de bruit que d'habitude j'ai
trouvé ça normalement je pense que c'est
paris à ses sous dans la gueule des gens
voilà
à 22h30 le sonomètre atteint les 69
décibels l'équivalent du bruit d'une
guitare électrique
alors que nous passons devant son
établissement en nous voyant film et un
barman historique vient à notre
rencontre et utilise l'argument de
l'emploi
ils m'ont fait enlever les terrasses
petit moi j'avais une autorisation
tacite des françaises ces incultes ou
parce que ça va faire deux personnes
employées en moi certaines filles il
n'aurait pas lieu d'être si ces gens là
et elle
face aux protestations des riverains
estimant leur business en danger les
bars contre attaque
ils ont fait de cet homme clément léon
un maire de la nuit on peut aller en
zone de conflit
du côté oui vous allez voir la zone de
conflit alors allons-y pour mieux
défendre les intérêts des noctambules
l'homme emmène la caméra vers les
endroits les plus calmes et montre une
certaine mauvaise foi pas bientôt fini
ce silence voilà alors nous sommes au
carreau du temple qui vient d'être
réouvert ya peu de temps et où ils
seraient censés avoir le chaos festif
avec des habitants autour quelques
habitants qui mettent des banderoles
voyez ici nous on la terrasse ici non à
la terrasse quartier en danger le
quartier est en danger en effet la vie
nocturne est en danger grâce à ces
quelques gens il est 22h donc à paris 22
heures c'est le coeur de la nuit pour
ces gens là aussi on est samedi soir en
ce jour de fête ne se passe rien parlé
un peu trop formation à notre initiative
il croise une vieille connaissance du
quartier
et vous pensez qu'il ya d'autres
personnes qui peuvent avoir besoin de
sommeil est bien suivi le regard dit
d'ailleurs bien sûr qu'il ya d'autres
personnes et je comprends pas en fait où
est le manque de sommeil là maintenant
par exemple samedi soir 23 heures
par exemple des riverains c'est une
pétition plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui disent qu'elle vit bruit
ou penser qu'ils ont tous alors je pense
que non pas du tout mais je pense que
solide je pense que je pense qu'une
centaine de personnes qui si une
pétition
j'en ai quatre cents pour eux derrière
qui est une pétition pour que le lieu
soit ouverte
vous méprisez les riverains qui vous
donne la donne
mais moi je n'entends pas j'entends pas
de bruit n'est pas du bruit j'entends
des gens qui parlent c'est la vie quoi
c'est la vie citadine voulait pas courir
surtout pas avec vous serra schoeters à
madame des gens sympathiques à la fête
avec vous d'ailleurs c'est un certain
dialogue de sourds n'y a pas de dialogue
même pas parce que non parce qu'à trop
de bruit
les patrons de bars viennent de marquer
un point un nouvel établissement devrait
ouvrir dès la semaine prochaine au coeur
du marais
[Musique]